we made it through another year so
what's worth
[Music]
remembering end of the year so yeah I
got to do that kind of standard YouTuber
thing and give a a top 10 however while
if you go further back I would do
specifically a top 10 movies list uh not
going to do that this year didn't do it
last year either
because I didn't rush out to see a lot
of movies this is this is not a great
year for movies a lot of high-profile
flops and a lot of the stuff that was
super successful either didn't interest
me or when I saw it I was
like so what this is going to be is just
a top 10 things that came out this year
or close I made one exception I'll
explain it when I get there that I think
are worth highlighting now that we've
hit the end of of the year before we do
that just quick thing about my own
experience of 2023 uh first half of the
year on a personal level was rough I'm
not going to get into it but the year
didn't start out
tremendous for me first half had a lot
of bumps um but once we got over the
halfway mark
roughly this just been okay or at least
it's made up largely for what it put me
through before um again I won't get into
personal life stuff but a lot of things
have been really wonderful with that and
the things that weren't have gotten
better so that feels good professionally
uh this is probably my best growth year
since I think it was
2016 uh was when like my growth first
started to explode and I'm pretty
positive this is my most lucrative year
in terms of um finances specifically
coming from YouTube and that both feels
good because I I've had years that have
felt pretty stagnant uh largely
plateaued that wasn't the case this year
um but it also feels a little weird
because the my most successful stuff
wasn't really the content that I want to
be known for I'm not embarrassed by any
of it but the fact that out of my top
three most viewed videos of the year uh
two of them were at least adjacent to
YouTube drama even though I don't really
consider either of them to be uh
specifically Drama videos I guess the
Illuminati one's a little closer to that
I definitely don't consider the
Summerton one to be um but that's
generally stuff that I try and avoid
talking about and trying to be very
careful about how I talk about it when I
do and then there was the video on trans
genocide which like I'm glad did well
because I worked really hard on that and
I think it's important that people
understand what is going on but you know
was also really depressing to make so
you know a year of big success in stuff
that I'm like boy be really nice if if
the thing that did really well this year
was something fun but I can't control
that and uh ultimately professionally
this has been this has been a good year
uh in a in a lot of way specifically in
regards to to all of this I won't bog
you down too much with my own personal
stuff if you want to hear me go into
more on that you can check out the uh
most recent episode of my podcast uh
there's a link in the description for
the podcast feed where um between having
finished discussing the original uh UK
show The Prisoner and before getting
back to Babylon 5 uh Jesse jender and I
just sort of talked to your wrapup and
we spent a bit longer going into detail
about our professional uh feelings about
how the year went so you can go there
for more details if you want them but
for
now what was good good this year these
are ranked but the rankings aren't that
significant well when we get to number
one it's kind of significant but anyways
let's go through
this number 10 Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves speaking of someone
who is not only old enough to have
remembered when the first Dungeons and
Dragons movie came out let their blood
rain from the
SK who but even beyond that this
captured for me what was the best thing
to try and transfer from the experience
of playing D and D to experience it as a
movie because if you try and capture a
sense of epicness that can sometimes
happen in a d andd session like it was
going to come across as generic like I I
love playing D and D do not get me wrong
but most of the time if you take the
experience of directly interacting with
the story out of it the actual
narratives are good but not not
exceptional they don't stand on their
own all that much they are booed by
doing it with people that you enjoy
being with and that's what this movie
captures the sense of this rag tag team
that are it's just fun to experience how
they bounce off each other the way their
abilities complement each other and just
capturing that sense of being around a
table with friends and transferring that
to the main group of this movie yeah it
captures that really really well and
that is what I had hoped would be
contained in this movie and it's right
there this was so much fun and that's
ultimately why I play DND D like there's
a lot I love about DND D and like
there's the gaming aspects which are fun
there is creating the story which is fun
but just the sense of building something
with these people that the real Joy of
playing that game for me and it's in
this and I couldn't be happier about
about
that number
nine super lesbian animal
RPG this is the one video game I'm going
to have on here um I don't tend to play
a lot of brand new video games there
were only a couple of games that I
played that actually came out this year
um I suppose I'll give an honorable
mention to one of them but I can't
really talk about it too much Scarlet
Maiden was actually shockingly good and
fun but I'm not I'm not going to get
into that one I will instead highlight
this one which technically came out in
2020 but it came out December 2020 it
was an independent release I played it
in 2023 so I'm bending the rules
slightly to uh to talk about this this
is just a wonderful throwback to 16bit
era style RPGs which I grew up on so
it's going of hit me in the Nostalgia so
other than just the visual presentation
and the mechanics bringing me to kind of
a happy place this is so wonderfully
wholesome it is a joy to play and to
experience these characters and and like
it's wholesome but it's not shallow
there's some wonderful character work
that is done uh particularly with the
character of Melody as the game goes on
and the story that unfolds is just
really lovely and to give you an idea of
what I mean by wholesome you know how
the standard thing in most RPGs
especially from the era that this is
evoking have that thing of like if you
can get into somebody's house and
there's a chest just open it that stuff
yours now like that's just how this
works or if you're Link in a Zelda game
you go in and you break all the pottery
um you try and go into a house that uh
does not appear to be occupied the
characters go like what are you doing
we're not going in there nobody's home
we're not invited what no we're not
going to do that that's what I mean by
wholesome it interrogates even some of
the base expectations of the genre in a
way that it's just beautiful and lovely
and fun I don't know if people who don't
have Nostalgia for the the 16 bit era
are going to get as much out of it as I
did but if you do have that Nostalgia
and you want something past style and
cute and really gay this
isah number
eight lowkey season
two I I struggled with the placement on
this if I had to attached the uh rest of
the season was only going to talk about
the finale this would be much higher
because the finale of this season and
presumably the finale of not only the
Loki TV show but Loki's story in the MCU
altogether is amazing it is better than
I could have ever hoped it was it does
some beautiful things in terms of
wrapping up the story and giving us
something satisfying with Loki itself
and there was this one visual moment
it's long enough ago I still don't want
to spoil it but you if you've seen it
you know where just just a visual you've
been seeing the whole time just you get
a different perspective on it entire
meaning changes and it was amazing to
see but I did make the decision to
consider the season as a whole and as
awesome as the finale is it's a little
uneven getting there not bad but I think
as an overall package the first season
was stronger as a complete experience
whereas this one had its ups and downs
but boy did it finish strong this
finished so well that it deserves a
place on the list even if it's not as
high as it would have been if I was only
talking about the
finale number number
seven good Omens 2 this is another one
that instinctively I kind of wanted to
put higher but I think a lot of it was
just the excitement of seeing David
Tenon and Michael Sheen together again
because those two together is just the
most wonderful thing and I do think this
is a very good followup on the first one
I did a whole video about it I've done
videos on most of these to varying
degrees either here or in the break room
of Geeks that's my secondary Channel go
ahead and subscribe to that if you
haven't but the thing is ultimately as
much as I do like it I went in assuming
this will get a third season which while
not confirmed at the time it came out
has now been that has been green lit
that is happening third season will be
the final one which is also good this
should have its def ending and not just
be strung out forever but this is
ultimately a middle chapter it's a good
middle chapter but it does have a lot of
the stuff that sort of comes with middle
chapter syndrome which is just a less
sort of sense of fulfillment and more of
a okay this is a this is a good way to
connect us from the beginning which was
great to the end which will hopefully be
great and it's still really good but you
know middle chapters they they're rarely
considered the best in a Continuing
Story situation for a reason but this is
a good middle chapter while still yes
very much being a middle chapter and
leaving uh quite a few things in an
unresolved state by the end in a way
that I felt satisfying but if this had
been the end yeah it wouldn't have felt
great it's booed by the fact that more
is coming thankfully but this was still
good number
six The Last of
Us I was surprised how much I liked that
show cuz I tried to play the game I
didn't get that far into it now
admittedly part of the problem with the
game for me was that it made me motion
sick my motion sickness with fully
rendered fully 3D uh free roaming camera
setups it's gotten real real bad I can
go maybe a half hour tops before I have
to stop and put the controller down so
I'm just
not it's just not conducive for me
anymore but even the story playing the
game like this is just such a downer I
don't know if I'm going to be into this
and initially I didn't jump on the show
right off because I assumed like this is
just going to bum me out but when I did
catch up after episode 3 came out and
there was a lot of Raving for it
rightfully so episode 3 is the best
episode but it's not a case of like lowy
season 2 where it's the best episode by
a massive margin it is the best episode
but they're all really good this whole
thing is framed really well with the
contrast between Joel and Ellie you
understand why Joel is the way he is but
as cliched as it is to have a younger
person in an apocalyptic scenario be you
know the light and the light and hope of
the human race and the beacon of the
future either metaphorically or
literally however any story chooses to
do it that is a
cliche but sometimes something manages a
clich idea so well you remember why it
was used so much to become a bit of a
cliche and this does that Dynamic really
really well the performances are
fantastic and I think this probably as a
story at least the impression I've
gotten again I didn't get that far in
the game I feel like the story probably
benefits from being able to cut out most
of the action scenes that were used to
connect the story bits in the game
because you had to have the action
scenes because that's the game part of
the game so what stops it from being a
walking simulator but here they only had
to have the action when it made
narrative sense to have it and I feel
like the balance and the times at which
things got intense in that way were
really well paced really well handled
and it's just
really really well executed the
emotional content of this even aside
from episode 3 which again is the best
is masterfully done I was surprised how
much I love this I'm nervous about
season 2 because my understanding of the
story of Last of Us Part Two makes me oh
God but I'm at least going to give it a
shot cuz I wasn't sure I'd like this
either and I really
did number five
the Doctor Who 60th anniversary specials
now at time of recording the Christmas
special hasn't aired yet so I can't take
that into consideration if I end up
really loving it I guess retroactively
lump that in as well but I'm going to
focus on the three specials that were
considered collectively the 60th
anniversary celebration featuring The
Return of David Tennant as the doctor
and Katherine tape returning as Donna
now I came into this hopeful but
skeptical because the very notion of
bringing back a previous doctor is an
idea I don't like and actually these
specials dealt with a number of ideas
that I think are fundamentally not great
ideas but there's something really
special about seeing a concept that you
don't think is a good
idea executed way better than you ever
thought it could be done I love when
that happens and that happened
particularly in the last uh of these
three specials the giggle when it came
to how shiga's doctor came about on
paper I think that's a terrible idea and
it's not that I now suddenly think it's
a good idea I think no that's still a
bad idea but you found a way to thread
the needle where this bad idea brings
about something beautiful and so it can
work now I debated breaking these up and
doing the doing specific ones rather
than doing them collectively I opted not
to because then uh Doctor Who specialist
would be taking up multiple spaces and
also I kind of don't want to tip my hand
on my ranking of these because one of
the First videos I'm going to do in the
new year is a ranking of all the Doctor
Who specials and that one will include
the Christmas one and I don't want to
give away where I rank these three in
advance cuz I don't know kind of want to
make you wait for that but all brought
together especially looking at them as
uh three parts of a whole it gave me
just the best sense of probably what
we're going to get going forward and
that first one was a warm nostalgic bath
the second one was delightfully weird
and off-putting and the third one did
what Russell T Davis is very good at
which is a big focus on the emotional
depth and payoff and maybe the logistics
are a little loose but boy did he hit me
in the fields all the
same this
was this was just
lovely watching these each time I just
felt good and that's
great number
four Black Mirror demons
79 now this is one whereas other shows
I've been talking about collectively
what they brought out you know all three
specials this season That season uh
Black Mirror I am just going to talk
about one episode because since they're
completely Standalone I feel like that's
more than fair this season of Black
Mirror was actually I think better than
a lot of people gave it credit for it
there were some stumbling blocks Beyond
the Sea Maisy day was better than people
thought it was but the stand out easily
for me was demon 79 which is the only
one I've gone back and rewatched since
it came out and it gets better the more
I think about it gets better every time
I see it just the the playing of the
characters off each other their Dynamic
is wonderful I love the idea of just of
a casual hanging out look I'm just
talking to you like this is what's going
on kind of Supernatural entity I just
like that as a dynamic and the way it
played off the politics well I was going
to say of the time of the time
reflective of how they are now and the
way that it integrated those things very
very naturally due to the nature of the
characters that it had and how it chose
to end oh this made me so happy if Black
Mirror feels like giving the rest and
transitioning to Red mirror where it's
going to be uh big focus on Supernatural
and less focus on technology I am on
board for this this has sold me on that
concept this was so good easily up there
with among the best episodes of the show
Full
Stop number
three the owl house watching and
dreaming the owl house was a wonderful
show and it was ended unfairly and
before it's time
thankfully we were granted some specials
to finish out the story and two of them
aired this year and while the the first
of the two that aired this year which
was the second of the three was good the
proper finale watching and dreaming was
just incredible it is so hard to bring a
satisfactory conclusion to frankly any
show especially one that was not allowed
to progress in the way that it was
intended and has to find a way to wrap
up satisfactorily in a format that it
was not intended to fit but this Nails
it this is beautifully satisfying
incredibly cathartic you find yourself
pumping your fist getting choked up and
just feeling the warm hug of these
characters the ow house has been great
from the beginning loose is actually I
think one of the best main characters
that has been in a series in a while I
have a tendency a lot of time to not
consider the lead characters in Things
especially a lot of the stuff that's
animated to be the most interesting
they're usually like okay like you're
moving the story along and that's good
but I'll gravitate much more towards a
lot of the side characters a lot of the
time loose is a really strong
protagonist and then in addition also
has an amazing Supporting Cast past and
you know bonus points for how gay it is
that wouldn't save it if it wasn't good
but it already is good so that's that
just makes it better for
me number
two across the spiderverse now I'm going
to put the asteris on this and bring up
my misgivings about how it was made the
crunch that the animators were put under
I did a whole video talking about that
and I'm very glad that the follow-up has
been delayed kind of indefinitely it is
being worked on it wasn't canceled but
they haven't got a set date on it which
is good and I really really really hope
that the situation for the animators
involved is significantly better because
this is an amazing piece of work
following up on into the spider versus
no small task that thing did a lot that
should not work introducing all these
characters a version of Spider-Man that
most people aren't familiar with killing
off uh something closer to the version
of Spider-Man people are familiar with
this entire concept of basically selling
the Multiverse before multiverses became
something of a cliche and now I don't
know about you I'm a little tired of
them already but and doing all that
while having a surprisingly tight and
focused story on a primary
character W that's a lot that is a lot
to try and pull together and the first
one did it and the idea of trying to
follow up on that when the newness and
boldness of the concept is kind of gone
it's not going to be as fresh just
inherently because we've seen it done at
least once by its predecessor and yet it
remembered focus on the characters it
gives wonderful Focus to Gwen miles
story is also really interesting and
compelling it introduces Miguel who is
in comic form at least my favorite
iteration of Spider-Man he's not at his
best in this but I don't mean it's a bad
depiction I mean they kind of leaned on
uh aspects of his character it's like
yeah if you're going to put him in a
slightly more antagonistic role those
are those are traits he has yeah yeah
you can pull that off but of course
naturally visually this is gorgeous it
takes a ble not even a b-l like a DL
villain and makes him not only a
compelling and interesting action
antagonist for miles and the rest of Sol
but makes him legitimately intimidating
and frightening and the focus on the
relationships the importance of
community and how it feels when the
community you thought would embrace you
doesn't it captures a lot of amazing
stuff in this and also you know a lot of
protrans messaging in this which again
would not have saved it if it wasn't
good but it is that's a bonus and again
to give you additional reading I did a a
video talking about how the trans
narrative is not limited to Gwen Stacy
if you want to do a full reading on it
this was an amazing thing and when I saw
it I thought that'll be my best movie of
the year that'll be the one I don't
think anything will beat
it well something
did number
one
nimona I cannot praise this movie Enough
I've done two videos on it already up to
this point talking about it on its own
merits and also as an
adaptation
this is the movie I've gone back and
rewatched the most I have cried
literally every single time I've praised
some of the other stuff for having you
know the gay aspects and that makes it a
little bit better and a little bit
brighter for
me this is the gayest thing I've seen in
a while want me to shifts you don't want
me to shifts pick a lan and now you're a
boy I am today or I guess querist is the
better word to use because I relate to
this very heavily as not only a trans
person but a gender fluid
transperson and the queerness is so
intrinsic to the story it is baked in
can you just be you please I don't
follow go you but I'm not a girl I'm a
shark unlike say across the spider verse
or even the owl house where the core
plot and narrative could still exist and
be largely the same if you stripped out
the gay aspects or transpositive aspects
of it it'd be worse for it don't get me
wrong I'm not calling those things
Superfluous but the core plot you could
still tell minus those elements here you
can't you can't you strip out the trans
and gay and queer allegory and just
Flatout depiction that is in this you
don't have a story
anymore this is fully baked in into
something
absolutely amazingly beautiful the
capturing of pneumonia and her sense of
anger rejection at everything she's been
through you understand why
she is the way that she is the Frank and
flat and just open and honest depiction
of someone who just doesn't fit in and
is okay with that but people won't leave
her alone why are you helping
me because I'm
bored and everybody hates you too she's
just trying to be but the society is
built around the idea of demonizing her
they grew up believing that they can be
a hero if they drive a sword into to the
heart of anything
different and I'm the monster so she
can't just be she's not allowed so
instead she's going to be a little chaos
Gremlin and I love her and the other
characters are also incredible this has
some significant deviations from The
Source material but it's all really
smart adaptations and all leaning more
into the metaphors and into the themes
of it and it captures the heart of what
so many queer people have been through
and struggled with in a way that is
beautiful and I think relatable even if
you don't have any form of lgbtqia plus
identity this is just
incredible like I I'm running out of
superlatives and I know there going to
be a weird thing to praise considering
the last movie I just praised is well
over two hours and did it and did need
that time I love love that it's short I
miss concise movies that know what they
are and get to their point and this does
this is
streamlined the perfect amount it's not
so stripped down that it's like boy
there's no depth here there's so much
depth they cram so much into every
minute delivered beautifully
anarchically this Punk sensibility great
soundtrack by the way
and it's just incredible Netflix make a
physical version of this available I am
begging
you I'm grateful that I I have access to
it
but I need to know that I have this
forever and that it will never be
stripped away because a digital platform
goes under or decides to purge it from
its system I need
this I've needed this movie for a long
time and now I have it and I don't ever
want to lose
it
neona was the best thing that came out
this year what do you think about any of
the stuff I've talked about or what do
you think was the best entertainment
that came out this year obviously
there's plenty of stuff to talk about
that I didn't cuz I skipped a lot of it
but whatever your thoughts might be drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe they all help me out but
what I really want you to remember as we
head into
2024 is that you are beautiful you are
valid and you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time for me to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin Moore
Zubin Lula goddess AA Oliver be to rock
the thing that goes going in the anime
Ruth goes to the gazarian solitary
pictures rrick bugden geek filter Linda
Walters toku BL huan Jen aune K8 Becky
Sparks rabi likes the poodle Robin
Powell TLO Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall white beish rosin Bennett po
baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and Mirra G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just I just didn't just didn't I
just didn't do a thing this time but now
I've told you that I didn't do a thing
so I've made a thing about there being
no thing okay thanks for sticking around
bye
y